Okay, Charles.
I'm going to see if I can get you to
derive a piece of the temporal
difference equation
just by working through this example
again in a slightly different way.
So from the last thing we talked about,
we said that the value estimate for
S1 after three episodes was 5.
And then we ran an episode, and
the return of that episode,
sort of the total discounted reward for
that episode, episode number 4,
starting from that state S1, was +2.
Could we just from this information
figure out what the new
estimate's going to be?
>> Sure.
>> So let's see if we can do that.
Let's work through that, step by step.
>> Oh, okay.
Well I can cheat right, by just, I mean
you have everything indexed by time so
I know that five is an estimate
of the last three, and
four is an estimate of the fourth one.
>> Right.
>> So, I should be able to, you know,
weight the first one with three,
and the other with one, or
something like that, and
that'll give me the right answer.
>> All right, so
what do you mean by weight?
So what you mean is since five is
the average of the first three episodes
then 15 is the total from
the first three episodes, right?
>> That's right.
I've seen it three times.
>> Good as if we had
seen five three times.
You know the details actually
varied from that but
that's okay because
averages work out nicely.
>> That's right doesn't matter.
>> Then we got an additional
reward of two and
now we want to know the average
over four steps right.
So that gives us 15 + 2 / 4 is 17/4
which is just the answer we had in
the quiz.
>> In fact that's exactly how I did it.
I just took the 15 over 3
that you had written down and
just said, oh so that would be 17/4.
>> Good.
So
let's generalize this a little bit and
put in some letters
because you know math.
So let's say instead that we're
talking about the previous estimate,
which was from time T minus 1.
Then we get a return on step T of T, and
now we want to compute the new estimate,
VT of S1.
So we should be able to do that
same kind of calculation with these
quantities just symbolically.
Okay so you want to try that again?
>> Sure.
So I think I know what
the VT of S1 is equal to.
(T-1) times V sub T-1 of S1 +
R sub T of S1 divided by T.
>> Good.
Which was four before, but
now in general it's T.
Excellent.
All right, so let's now do
a little bit of algebra on this.
>> Oh, sure.
>> So first I'm just going to divide
through by this capital T, and
split it into two pieces of the sum.
>> Okay.
>> All right, so
then we can regroup things as follows.
Let's see, so I guess, mainly the idea
is that we split this T-1 over T
into a T over T, and a -1 over T.
So that gets us (VT-1(S1)) + (1 over
T (RT(S1))- (VT-1(S1)).
So I wrote it kind of funky.
I introduced this additional learning
rate parameter, alpha sub T,
the learning rate at times step T, but
it's really just playing the role
of one over T here, the averaging.
But there's an interesting thing that
popped out of this particular way of
rewriting it.
In that we are looking at kind of
a temporal difference that our update
to the value is going to equal the
difference between the reward that we
got at this step and the estimate
that we had at the previous step.
And so this difference is actually
going to drive the learning.
So if the difference is zero
then things don't change.
If the difference is big positive
then it goes up then if it's
big negative then it goes down.
And as we get more and
more episodes this learning parameter
is getting smaller and smaller so we're
making smaller and smaller changes.
We're kind of honing in on
the actual true values.
>> So this actually looks just like
the update rule for perceptrons.
Yes, yes, and in fact that was I believe
that what Sutton was trying to do.
He wanted to make
temporal predictions and
he wanted to put it into the same kind
of algebraic framework that people were
familiar with from perceptron learning
and from neural net learning.
>> Right, so if we did it that way
then RT minus V sub T is the error.
>> Very good.
Yeah, that's a great way to look at it.
That we're making our update
based on moving a little bit in
the direction of there.
>> Right, moving less and
less and less as time goes on,
which is just what you're supposed
to do at the learning rate.
>> Exactly.
>> So, let me asks a question
along those lines then.
So if alpha sub T was not 1 over T but
something else, like I don't know, 1
over the square root of T or something.
Some other way of doing a learning rate.
>> Uh-huh
>> You would get a slightly different
answer at any given time.
But would you expect to kind of
converge to the same answer ultimately?
>> That is a really good question.
In fact that is the next
question I was going to ask.
>> Oh wow.
I feel better now.
>> [LAUGH] So here it comes.